-I'm so happy
you're back on the show.
Thank you so much
for being our guest.
And I wanted to thank you
because I was lucky enough
to be on "CBS Sunday Morning,"
where you interviewed me.
-And that was really fun.
-It was fun.
You were in my home.
-I was in your home
and I was in your lair,
your sanctum sanctorum,
your vinyl room.
-Yes, my record --
-Which is amazing.
And not just because you have
an amazing library of LPs,
but really because
you have a whole section
devoted to show tunes,
to Broadway shows.
So objectivity
was out the window then.
-Really? Yeah.
Did you expect -- Do you
learn more about people
when you interview
them in their homes?
-Yeah, I think so.
I mean, listen, when I've been
on this show before --
and I really mean this -- your
love of music is so palpable.
I can feel it when bands are on,
you know,
and the camera's not on you.
I can feel how into it you are,
but being in the vinyl room,
I could really feel it
and your love of it.
and just, like,
the equipment and everything
and the dusting
of the records.
I mean, you really
care about it.
And after the show,
a bus will be leaving
to go out to your vinyl room,
so everyone --
-Yeah, everyone come to my house
and to my little room.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Here's a photo of us
in the vinyl room.
I think we were dancing.
-To "Little Shop of Horrors."
-"Little Shop of Horrors."
-As one does.
-That's right.
You found
"Little Shop of Horrors."
You go, "Let's put this one on,"
because I'm like,
"Listen to this system,
it's so good."
And we were playing like
Led Zeppelin or whatever.
And I go, "Isn't that crazy?"
And you go,
"We got to listen to this."
And then you put that on,
and we both started dancing,
'cause, like...
♪ Little shop ♪
♪ Little shop of horrors ♪
Oh, that was so good.
Oh, it was so fun.
I want to talk
about "Mobituaries."
It's a fascinating show.
I know it sounds a little
morbid, being about obituaries,
but it's not actually.
It's very interesting and it's
charming, actually, and nice.
-Listen,
I'm a fan of obituaries,
which I know sounds weird.
I got it from my father,
and my father was not
a gloomy person at all.
He was a very, like,
buoyant, optimistic person.
-Why did he like it?
-Because a good obituary
is about someone's life.
It's not about their death.
And a good one, when I read it,
it's kind of like a trailer
for an Oscar-winning biopic.
It kind of has
a sweep and a romance,
like, the highs, the lows,
the triumphs, you know,
the hopefully
not too many tragedies.
But, yeah,
that's how a good one reads.
I mean, I'm not that interested
in how people die.
I'm interested kind of
in their beginnings
and sort of
the arc of their lives.
But it's a great beat,
and, I mean, on newspapers,
the ones that still
have obit departments,
it's really kind of coveted,
because
if you're writing for it,
you're writing for,
like, the sports section,
for entertainment, for business,
depending on who dies.
-Wow. Yeah, you're right.
-Yeah.
-And it's always a downer
at the end there, but --
-No. Well, sometimes,
it's not even about people.
Sometimes, it's about the death
of things or an idea.
Like, last week was --
-The last week's episode
was the death of
the old-timey Hollywood accent.
So, I mean, anyone certainly
under a certain age,
if you turn on, say,
Turner Classic Movies,
black-and-white movies,
everyone's speaking in something
that has commonly been called
the Mid-Atlantic accent.
Like, they don't pronounce
their R's.
They say things like,
"It's mah-velous."
And you're like,
"What is that accent?"
And, you know, like,
Bette Davis, Orson Welles,
all these great stars --
Katharine Hepburn had it.
And then it just
sort of disappeared.
And it's interesting.
It was a real accent, though.
It was not a put-on.
People back then, in the
Northeast of the country
especially,
really talked that way.
-Yeah. And why, though?
Because it was --
You traced it back to theater?
-Well, some of it, yeah.
So, what happened is, over time,
the R's kind of were sanded off
the ends of people's words.
They just really started talking
in that way where they --
-They go "thah."
-Yeah, that. Yeah, exactly.
Yeah, "thah."
-Look out "thah."
-Yeah. What a wonderful
"yea" this is.
-Yeah, what a "yea."
We're not "heah." We're "thah."
-Or, you know -- Or the donkey
in "Winnie the Pooh"
was "Eeyoh."
It wasn't like "Eeyore."
You didn't pronounce your R's.
And it just kind of went away.
And in the theater,
it was really effective
because, you know,
the accent also involved
enunciating,
kind of elongated vowels.
And it would travel
to the back of the house
when there were no microphones.
And then Hollywood adopted it.
But there were people,
like the Roosevelts,
you know,
who really spoke in this way.
And then Marlon Brando just kind
of drove a stake through it --
-Yeah. "I'm not doing this."
-Yeah, he wasn't going to do it.
So, he was in
"Streetcar Named Desire"
in 1951, in the movie.
And he didn't say like,
"Stellah, Stellah!"
Like, he talked like
a normal person.
-Can you imagine?
Yeah, it was like,
"Stellah, Stellah.
What are you doing up thah?
Stella!"
Yeah, exactly.
Guys, there's more stories
like that and more.
You're going to love it.
Mo Rocca, "Mobituaries."
Listen to it wherever
you get your podcasts --
iHeart, whatever you want to do.
We'll be right back with
a performance from Bleachers.
Stick around.